okay computer station let's go right
slightly similar to couple of levels
Wow Jim's sticking to the ceiling
delicious
this is very maze-like sir well supposed
to do is I've just going around
aimlessly right that's small people
shooting
disconcerting noise they make okay
maybe yellow key boom so sphere I would
quite like to get data and I need a red
key I need all the keys anyone have any
keys I want a bell in here ah okay first
key good at least we're moving along
this is a very complex level design
makes me know this almost-dead need to
kill things as quickly as possible now I
don't know where they are
they just good for its weight remember a
secret Harry being there um I can't even
believe I forgot to mention this the
other edition do Britt will do is one of
the music backs it's not the traditional
music as I'm sure everyone is aware of
by now just thought I'd mention it good
modern music whilst I do think the
original music is amazing I just think
it's good to modernize things as much as
possible whilst keeping the real
original spirit of the game yeah I just
hold those
that was a good barrel placement good
Wow
this is becoming quite hairy I really
need to fight off now sorry
Oh No I nearly need to find some health
I'm gonna go for it dad elf ah good good
oh really was dangerously close to a KO
oh not good
good good good
apologies I'm anxious there for a second
don't seem to be hitting him hitting
that though
now I feel much better much more relaxed
much more relaxed
that's right I still don't have that kid
I get this boundless good I have the
yellow key I have the health I think
there is a secret room near ya memory
serves I think it's here yeah let me
smell you that is because you need to
know where it is to get back in you jump
through their window right so I need to
find a red key need the red key and the
blue key preferably see that was the
yellow key in there
what was this do I know that is still
the key
No looks like the key wasn't there
most it was the chainsaw which I already
have
although say now did deal will make
chains also that's how this mod worked
clearly not okay what do you see pushing
about just checking for switches
no such luck haha
Mago till I that was extremely
satisfying right try to sneak up on his
back huh
not as satisfying as rocket launcher in
$15 but still bike
just about all for safety you know I
definitely have not been down here good
there's the blue key which I need but
how do I get to it through there all
right well that was a jump okay
back up back up always we have enough
will always be reloading always be
shooting make sure someone in the
comments will turn that into electro red
key okay one line is the blue key and
I've got on
always with the demons always with the
demons where is he now
bye-bye okay
looky next has to be down here to the
left right
I think it knows because more enemies
respond to sign
it's an ethicist I'm Maria I've been out
there before although there are enemies
back now so I think that is where the
blue key will take me but I don't have
it I keep on forgetting so used to just
opening doors is this okay it's
definitely down this way it has to be
yes red key of course so the only reason
I needed the red key was to get the blue
key Wow
okay now wait a minute we're to be
fairly certain I'd be this way before
all right not too excited in the health
front if I get a room with demons that
will not be fun no I finally go through
here
good that okay well that's the level
exit okay
right okay that's what that's which did
good
I should be fine ah just waiting for
them to come to me I'm not gonna bother
them down there I have computer station
duh I think this is the last level
Formosan on Phobos anomaly should I say
alright that was easy
this is always a sign always the side of
a boss when they give you easy enemies
and every single health back in the game
and a computer area map okay this is
making me very nervous and
- Damon seems of it a chain gun with all
the ammo I could possibly need and the
shotgun yeah I think this is I'm fairly
certain this is where the bosses think
this is the hell night oh this - oh good
okay
at about 50 invisible demons good okay
I'm just gonna use the chin up here
because I'm scared I'm very very scared
it's me no more left
no okay
well I'm not sure how many bullets
we died very quickly
and I imagine so will his friend okay
well they were bosses but they weren't
really that hard hmm
don't think I want to go down there
again I don't think I'll be able to get
back up again no mind I'll get more ammo
just in case this is the only switch I
can see so I'm going to press it
ominous ominous staircase well it's a
pentagram reground so what okay I think
that's the end of knee-deep in the dead
once you'd be the big badasses and clean
out the moon base you're supposed to win
aren't you aren't you where's your fat
room warden ticket home
what the hell is this it's lots of post
end this way
it stinks like rotten meat but looks
like the los demás base looks like
you're stuck on the shores of hell the
only way out is through to continue the
doom experience play the shores of Hell
and it's amazing sequel inferno well
thank you very much for watching and I
hope to see you again next time
and as always I am The Cure
you